hi in this session i'd like to talk
about interest rates
now if you think about it we're
surrounded by interest rates right but
an interest rate
is the rate that you pay if you're a
borrower of money and a rate you receive
if you lend money out but when you look
around you
these are the rates you see you see
fixed deposits rates when you go into a
bank
and think about depositing your money in
a cd
you see mortgage rates and you've got to
borrow money to buy a house you see
rates you can earn on money market funds
when you invest
in a through a brokerage account or
credit rates you pay on your credit card
if you fail to make your
entire credit card due payment on the
date that it's due
so we're surrounded by rates and it's
easy to get confused about where these
rates come from why they're different
why they move in different directions
broadly speaking if you look at how
interest rates are said
you can put them into four groups the
first are market set rates or market
determined rates set by demand and
supply
the rate you earn on commercial paper or
a table or a t-bond is a market set rate
the second are market influencer rates
these are rates that somebody sets but
they set it based upon a market-based
rate
for instance the rate you see on fixed
deposits
or your mortgage rate might not be set
by a market directly but they are
influenced by what's happening
in the treasury market in terms of
treasury rates going up or down
some rates are set by entities by banks
by central banks
by credit card companies they tend to be
a little more rigid it's not
quite clear what they're based on so
indirectly even they
might be affected by what those market
determined rates are
and finally if you're negotiating with
somebody to take a loan the rate you
come up with is a negotiated rate
that trade too is affected by
market-based rates
in other words market determined rates
are at the foundation for
all of the interest rates you see
whether they show up
immediately or over time depends on how
flexible the rate you're looking at is
and how
often it's reset so let's take the most
visible of these market determined rates
which is the rate on a u.s treasury
in u.s treasuries of course are bonds
issued by the u.s government
they can be short-term they can be
long-term here i've looked at the rates
on a three-month
table which is towards the very end the
lowest end of the
maturity spectrum shortest term and
10-year t-bonds which is the most
widely traded of the u.s treasury bonds
now of course there are 30-year bonds
and 20-year bonds so i'm going to focus
on the 10-year bond and the 3-month
table in this graph
i've graphed out what these numbers have
looked like since 1928
and you can see the table rate and the
t-bond rate generally move together when
one goes up
the other goes up and one goes down the
other goes down there are periods of the
two seem to move in different directions
we'll come back and talk about it
because that is what drives what's
called the yield curve so you've got
short-term rates and long-term rates
over the last 15 years in addition to
these rates and these rates incidentally
are nominal rates what does that mean
you invest in dollars you receive the
money in dollars
and to the extent that there's inflation
it's it eats away your returns
now for the last 15 years you had
another
another choice to make in the treasury
market you can invest
in an inflation-protected t-bond it's
called a tips and here's how it works
instead of guaranteeing your nominal
rate of return so when you buy a 10-year
t-bond for instance
you're given a three percent coupon the
coupon is fixed
it's guaranteed with the tips you're not
guaranteed a fixed rate of return you're
guaranteed a real
interest rate of one percent and to the
extent that there's inflation
that inflation gets added on that way
you're guaranteed the one percent return
what does that mean
if inflation is only two percent you
make a three percent return if inflation
jumps to ten percent you make eleven
percent return
so tips rate is a real interest rate
now this is as good a time as any to
introduce one of my favorite equations
that helps me understand interest rates
i'm a simplest it's some i am simplistic
and this does help it's called the
fischer equation
the fisher equation is just a breakdown
of a nominal interest rate
into what a real interest rate and
expected inflation
so when you have a five percent nominal
rate the fischer equation says some of
that is for expected inflation some of
it is a real interest rate
now real interest rates are a function
of how much we prefer
current consumption so we invest as
investors collectively prefer current
consumption more the real interest rate
will go up
but over time the real interest rate is
also tied to real growth
when growth has been high real interest
rates have tended to be high
when growth is low real interest rates
are low i'll tell you why i like the
fischer equation
the fisher equation helps me understand
why rates change over time
why they're higher sometimes and lowered
others and why they might even become
negative
if inflation is high and real growth is
strong you should expect to see the
normal interest rate be high
if you have deflation and some some
economies some currencies you do
and real growth is very low or even
negative
now you can have negative interest rates
that's an easy answer the question
can rates become negative yes it's
unusual but it's not unnatural
now let's see how well the fischer
equation works
for the last few years i've been
computing what's called an intrinsic
risk free radius and what the heck is an
intrinsic risk
free rate every year i track two numbers
i track the inflation rate that year and
the real gdp growth that year
remember i said in the long term real
growth and real interest rates converge
i'm going to take a simplistic view
let's assume the real growth in any year
is the real interest rate in that year
i add the inflation rate to the real
growth rate so i'll take an example
you know inflation rate now five six
years ago was two percent the real
growth rate was one and a half percent
two plus one and a half percent
is three and a half percent i call that
my intrinsic risk free rate
see the black line that is my intrinsic
risk free rate computed by
adding together then i'm sorry the see
the columns the gray column plus the
blue
those numbers put together is my
intrinsic risk free rate
the black line is a smoothed out version
of that you're saying smooth dot forward
inflation tends to jump around i use
average growth and average inflation so
it's a much better measure of that
intrinsic risk free rate because it
smooths out year-to-year differences
take a look at the black line in the red
line
the black line is what the rate should
have been given inflation and real
growth smoothed out
the red line is what it actually was hey
do the two move together
in my at least for my eyes they
certainly do
in fact if you look at the breakdown of
intrinsic risk free rates and t-bond
rates by decade you can see
over the decades how the two have been
tied together
so as you go through time you see that
when inflation is high
and growth is high 70s for instance
interest rates are high
and it also answers the question why
have rates been low
over the last decade and don't be so
quick i know you're going to say because
the fed will
to be so the fed has had an effect but
rates have been low
for the last decade for a simpler reason
inflation has been low
and real growth has been anemic low
inflation plus low growth
gives you low rates it's a federation
effect as we'll see in a minute has
but the real driver of interest rates
over time is inflation
and real growth so now let's talk about
central banks
if you listen to cnbc if you read what
financial
gurus think about the market you would
think central bank set rates
that is the perception that's often
given why are rates low because of fed
lowered rates well there's a very simple
response to that
the fed does not set rates it doesn't
set the table rate it doesn't set the
t-bond rate it doesn't even set your
mortgage rate
the fed actually drives only one
rate and it's not even a very widely
used rate it's called the fed funds rate
it's a rate at which commercial banks
can borrow and lend
each other on an entry-day basis it's a
really short-term rate that only banks
can use
am i saying the fed has no power to set
rates of course not
when the fed changes the fed funds rate
it's sending a signal to the market
and to the extent that the fed is viewed
as this all-powerful entity
the power of that signal is directly
correlated with how much power investors
think the fed has
no i'm talking in circles but i've
described the fed as the wizard of oz
remember the wizard of oz the power of
the wizard came from the perception that
the wizard had power it was it really
had no power but that perception was
enough
central banks get their power from the
perception that they have power
in fact to isolate what the fed has had
the effect the fed has had
here's what i did see these blue columns
that's the difference between the
10-year t-bond rate and the intrinsic
risk-free rate over time
i've graphed it out against the the
basically i've graphed it out against a
fed funds rate over this period
and you can see as you look at the fed
funds rate the fed funds rate has been
no but the effect of the fed funds rate
on
on overall rates has been fairly small
it's not
it's not zero obviously but the effect
has been small
so when people talk about the fed
setting interest rates one of the
questions you might want to ask them is
what rate does the fed set
central banks are power but the
perception of power is what gives them
that power
now of course over the last last 12
years
central banks have become much more
activist in the interest rate market
in fact after the 2008 crisis fed
the fed in particular but central banks
across the world
started on a process called quantitative
easing just a fancy word for
the fed was actually buying bonds in the
treasury market
and remember when you have a large
player buying bonds in the treasury
market rates are going to go down
it's had an effect on rates quantitative
easing has lowered rates because the fed
has been buying bonds
but if you track how much the fed has
actually spent buying those bonds over
time
the effect is small and it's up early
so even after they stopped buying bonds
the rates stayed low
so as we while critics might just
attribute everything that happens to
interest rates to central banks the
reality
actually is different central banks
influence rates
they don't set them one final point
about interest rates before we move
on when you looked at the three-month
table rate in the 10-year bond rate you
notice that they
move together most of the time but
sometimes moved in different directions
in fact the yield curve measures rates
at different maturities
and generally speaking yield curve can
take one of three forms so basically
yield curve you plot rates for three
months one year two year five year
tenure on the same graph
yield curves can be take one of three
forms one is they can be upward sloping
where long term rates are higher than
short-term rates
second they can be flat but long-term
and short-term rates are pretty similar
and sometimes
they can be downward sloping you're
saying who cares in a minute i'll come
to that
but if you look across time rates most
of the time
reflect an upward sloping yield here for
instance i've taken the entire decade
from 2010 through 2018.
you see for the most part rate slope
upwards in fact if you look at the hunt
last 100 years the predominant
slope for the yield curve has been an
upward sloping vehicle
but as i said once in a while you get
downward sloping yield curves but before
i look at downward sloping yield curves
let's think about why the yield curve
might be upward sloping
to the extent that inflation is built
into rates maybe it's because people
expect higher inflation in the future
but that would be odd that people always
through the last hundred years the other
is and this is an argument that was made
a long time ago
is maybe investors demand a maturity
premium for buying a long-term bond as
opposed to short-term bill why because
if inflation becomes volatile and you're
uncertain about the future
maybe you'll demand a premium for buying
longer term rates or longer term bonds
whatever the reason though the
conventional yield curve
is upward sloping but once in a while it
does get downward sloping and people
freak out
why because take an example this was the
on december 4th of 2018. it wasn't even
the entire year cover
portion of the yield curve became
downward sloping you can see
it's between the two year and the five
year and people were convinced that the
end of the world was coming
why because if you look at downward
sloping yield curves over time
there is at least this indirect evidence
the downward sloping yield curve
seem to preview a decline in the economy
that economic growth is going to
drop off maybe even a recession so a
downward sloping yield curve has been
used by many as a signal that the
economy is going to go
into a slowdown or a recession and often
they back it up with a graph and the
graph actually looks very powerful
so basically what you see in this graph
is the spread between the two ear and
the ten-year bond which is what people
have often used as a measure of the
yield curve
and what happens in terms of the economy
so the grades are all the recession
periods
you can already see that quite a few of
the recessions that have happened over
the last 50 years
have been preceded by a downward sloping
gear gun
so this seems like a slam dunk right
downward sloping yield cup
economy is going to go into recession
start selling stocks
well before you jump to that conclusion
i think
that we need to take a deeper look
remember the
before the yield curve becomes downward
sloping it first becomes flat so maybe
rather than throw away all the data and
just look at whether the yield curve is
upward and downward sloping
we should just look at the difference
between three month and one year rates
one year and two year rates
and look to see whether there's a
correlation between
the differences between those rates and
what happens the economic growth
and i did that in fact i looked at ra
the the difference between
different maturities two and ten two and
three one one and three
essentially i graphed them out over time
and real gdp growth every year
and my objective was to see if there was
a correlation
between how upward sloping the yield
curve was
and how well the economy does remember
the conventional wisdom is
the more upward sloping the yield curve
the better the economy does
well take a look at this table what the
best way to read the table is to look at
the slope of the yield curve and and
look at the correlation between that and
real gdp growth in the next quarter in
the next year
remember if the slope of the yield curve
is a very good predictor
of gdp growth upward sloping yield
curves and high growth go together
this correlation should not just be
positive but it should be a high number
how high remember correlations are
capped at one so it should be a number
of points
not you make a you know you make
you make your own judgment on what's
happened 0.4.5.6
i'll start with the good news when i
look from 1962 through 2018 the
correlation is positive that's good news
because that's at least
mildly supportive of the notion that
when the youth curve is upward sloping
gdp growth is higher but it's generally
the short end of the spectrum which
seems to have the positive correlations
even over the entire time period if you
look at the longer term rates five year
versus two year ten year versus two year
the correlation is negative upward
sloping yield curves have not been good
predictors of gdp growth over the last
56 years
of between 1962 and through 2018.
if our focus on the 10 years since the
2008 crisis
things seem to have shifted even more in
fact the relationship between the yield
curve and gdp growth has become almost
perverse
downward sloping yield curves or less
upward sloping yield curves seem to
be more associated with higher growth
than more upward sloping yield curves
what changed i think the behavior of the
fed change and it's created some
permanent shifts in how the economy
reacts to yogurts
now i'm not saying there's no
information in the slope of the yoga
but i'm saying be cautious because you
will see people throw out roots of thumb
based on a very long history and those
rules of thumb
don't seem to work very well anymore so
let's summarize
what we've talked about with interest
rates interest rates can be market set
or market influence if their market's
set
they will move over time what causes
them to move over time
put simply changes in expectations about
inflation
and changes in real interest rates and
if you're trying to explain the movement
of a market set rate like the us
treasury rate over time
go back to inflation and real growth and
central banks
at best influences those rates they
can't set those rates
put simply if inflation was seven
percent right now
there's nothing central banks can do to
keep the rates at one or two percent
at the margin central banks are players
in the game
they don't write the rules in the game
so we'll come back and talk more about
interest rates in the context of
valuation
but it's good to have this foundation
laid
before we embark on more ambitious
pursuits
thank you